why do you think voters don't crush your
party with rnhs there's another question
on trust david cameron why do you think
voters don't trust your party with the
nhs all i can say is what i think what i
believe and when my disabled son was
desperately ill i went to the nhs night
after night i went to different
hospitals i was in different places but
i got the most fantastic care support
and i'd say love from those people in
the nhs for my family and for my son it
was always there for me and i will
always make sure it is there for other
families in our country now i showed you
that note about we had no money when we
became the government when we got that
note we still made a very big decision
which is we said yes we're going to have
to make cuts in some areas of government
spending but the nhs is going to get
more money every year i'm prime minister
and it has had more money and that's why
there are compared with when i became
prime minister nine thousand more
doctors there are seven thousand more
nurses were carrying out millions more
operations every year do i think it's
perfect no i don't and i've got a big
ambition for the next five years which
is to deliver a seven day a week nhs
including seven day opening eight in the
morning eight in the evening for gp
surgeries i know we can do that because
we're already delivering it to about
eight million people in our country if
you elect me as prime minister i'll
finish the job and make sure we have
seven day opening for gp surgeries right
across our country that will really help
working people to access the nhs that we
all want